APRIL TWENTY FIRST ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WE
HAVE NINETY THREE BILLS TO
CONSIDER THIS MORNING SO WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE FAST BEFORE WE
BEGAN I HAVE A FEW HOUSEKEEPING
NOTES TO COVER. FIRST I WANNA.
THINK WHEN THEY GET HERE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN AND
MCCARTY FOR COVERING VACANCIES
TODAY. AND I LIKE TO THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD WHEN HE
GETS HERE PREPARING FOR MR
BONTA. WE'RE KEEPING PHYSICAL
DISTANCE- FROM ONE ANOTHER AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITAL WELL I
HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WHO CAN WATCH IN PERSON- AND I
SEE NINE HERE SO WE WILL NOT
GIVE THEM. ANY INSTRUCTIONS. WE
WILL BE TAKING- PUBLIC COMMENT
BEFORE THE CLOSE OF THE HEARING
THE CALL IN LINE FOR TESTIMONY
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN IN
THE ACCESS CODE IS TWO FOUR TWO
SIX TWO THREE SEVEN. THE
CONFIRMATIONS ALSO AVAILABLE ON
THE DAILY FILE AND ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE IF YOU HAVE
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE DIRECTLY IN MY STAFF
WILL HELP YOU. I ALSO WANT TO
NOTE THAT WE ACCEPT WRITTEN
TESTIMONY SO IF FOR SOME REASON
YOU DON'T GET YOUR TESTIMONY
AND YOU CAN DO THAT. THROUGH
THE POSTAL SERVICE IS DESCRIBED
ON APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. THANK YOU- IT FOR
BEARING WITH US I DO WANT TO
REMIND PEOPLE THAT WERE VERY
SPECIFIC IN OUR RULES SO THOSE
AT HOME WHO ARE CALLING IN. IF
YOU ARE MAIN WITNESS IDENTIFIED
BY THE AUTHOR YOU WILL HAVE TWO
MINUTES TO PRESENT IT MUST BE
ABOUT THE FISCAL ISSUES AND
NOTHING ELSE. AFTER THAT WE GO
TO PUBLIC COMMENT AND WE DO NOT
ALLOW ANYTHING EXCEPT PEOPLE'S
NAME AND THEIR POSITION ON A
BILL. IF SOMEBODY DOESN'T ABIDE
BY THE RULES WE WILL CUT YOU
OFF- AND ASK YOU TO STOP
CALLING IN IF YOU CONTINUALLY.
DON'T ABIDE BY THE RULES AT
OTHERWISE IF THERE IS ANY
DISRUPTION IN THE CAPITOL
BUILDING- WE WILL ASK PEOPLE TO
BE REMOVED. WITH THAT. WE ARE
GOING TO START AS THE-
SUBCOMMITTEE I WE HAVE A QUORUM
WONDERFUL PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GONZALEZ I YOUR PRESENCE
BIGELOW PRESENT TO RECORD.
CALDERON CARILLO GEL DAWALY
DAVIES. ONE ZERO IN ORDER FOR
YOUR- LEVINE COURT ROBERT RIVAS
FRIEDMAN MCCARTY. THANK YOU-
AND WITH THAT WE WILL START
WITH MISS AGUIAR-CURRY SHE IS-
PRESENTING ON AB FIVE THIRTY
FIVE- SHE HAS. EIGHT DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. IT'S
AGUIAR-CURRY. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB FIVE THIRTY FIVE
WHICH CLOSES LOOPHOLE THE
CALIFORNIA'S TRUTH IN LABELING
LAWS IN CALIFORNIA ALL OF OIL
ESTABLISHES CLEAR GUIDELINES ON
WHEN THE ALL OF THE OIL
INDUSTRY CAN USE THE TERM
CALIFORNIA ON ITS LABELING AND
MARKETING. I DO NOT ANTICIPATE
IN THE CHAIR OBVIOUSLY CONCURS
BECAUSE THIS BILL WAS PROPOSED
FOR CONSENT. BUT THIS
CLARIFICATION RESULT IN
SIGNIFICANT COSTS. IN
INSIGNIFICANT CROSSES HIS IN
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND SAFETY
CODE STATES AND I QUOTE. IF ANY
ALL OF OIL IS PRODUCED IN
PROCESS SOLD OFFERED FOR SALE
GIVEN AWAY OR POSSESSING
CALIFORNIA THAT INDICATES
UNSTABLE CALIFORNIA OLIVE OIL.
OR USES WORDS OF SIMILAR IMPORT
THAT INDICATE THE CALIFORNIA IS
THE SOURCE OF THE OLIVE OIL A
100% OF THE OIL SHALL BE
DERIVED FROM OLIVES GROWN IN
CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA LAW ALSO
PROTECTS REGIONS IN OUR STATE
OF SPECIAL IMPORTANCE LIKE
NAPPING MY ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
UNFORTUNATELY OUT OF STATE
CORPORATIONS PURCHASING
CALIFORNIACOMPANIES UTILIZING
THE STATE'S GOOD NAME HAVE
BEGUN BY PASSING CALIFORNIA
STANDARDS ARE REPLACING THEIR
OILS WITHOUT OF STATE AN
INTERNATIONAL PRODUCT. THE
LEGACY NAMES DECEIVE THE
CONSUMER AS ANYONE COULD SEE
FROM COMPLAINTS FROM AMAZON
FROM THOSE MISLED BY LABELING.
THE CALIFORNIA OLIVE OIL
INDUSTRY HAS WORKED HARD TO
DEVELOP SOME OF THE MOST
STRINGENT QUALITY STANDARDS IN
THE WORLD. ALLOWING OUT OF
STATE CORPORATE BUYERS TO
PROPER FOR MISLEADING LABELS
THAT ULTIMATELY DAMAGE THE
INDUSTRY IS SOMETHING WE CANNOT
CONTINUE TO ALLOW. WE HAD AN
EXTREMELY LENGTHY AND ROBUST
DISCUSSION OF THE POLICY IN
ASSEMBLY HELP LAST WEEK A
SPECIAL MOST ESPECIALLY WITH
YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR. WHERE
THE BILL EMERGED WITH THE
THIRTEEN OH BIPARTISAN VOTE. I
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS INCLUDING THE MEETINGS
THAT I'VE ALREADY SCHEDULED. AS
LONG AS THEY ARE WILLING TO BE
HONEST WITH WITH THE CONSUMERS
ABOUT THE NATURE OF THE
PRODUCT. AGAIN BECAUSE THIS
BILL IS MERELY CLOSING A
LOOPHOLE IN THE EXISTING LAW. I
AGREE WITH THE COMMITTEES SENSE
THAT THIS WILL HAVE MINIMAL
FISCAL IMPACT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE TODAY AND
HERE TO TESTIFY IS LOUIS BROWN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA COALITION.
OF TRUTH IN ALL OF OUR LABELING
AND CAROLINE BEALE HUNTER
REPRESENTING YOUR TO DO HERE
THANK YOU. KAEL AN OPERATOR
WILL GO TO THE- WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. BERMAN HERE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE REALLY BROWN
CALLING TODAY ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION ALL OF OIL
LATELY OF THE AUTHOR SAID IT
WELL THE DALLAS THE POINTS OUT
THERE THEY'RE VERY LIMITED- AND
MINIMAL FISCAL IMPACTS THIS
BILL SO ON THE FISCALLY HUGE WE
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE I COULD BE
AVAILABLE. TO READ YOUR
QUESTION AT. THANK YOU WILL GO
TO THE NEXT WITNESS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE CAROLYN BILL
HUNTER ON BEHALF OF YOUR TODAY
HE WENT TO NATION A FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBE AND YELLOW
COUNTY. AND WE- ALSO AGREED AT
THEIR VERY MINIMAL COST TO THIS
BILL AND BUT APPRECIATE YOUR I
FELT. ILL TODAY HE HAS BEEN AN
AWARD WINNING OLOVO PRODUCER OF
CALIFORNIA GROWN OLIVES AND
BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL IS
IMPORTANT TO- PROVIDE THE-
ACCURACY IN ON AT THE DEBATE TO
ENSURE THAT THERE'S NOT AN
ETHICAL UNSAFE FOOD- I'M
TRYING. TO ENSURE THAT NOT AN
ETHICAL OR UNSAFE FOOD PRODUCTS.
PUT FORTH TO CALIFORNIA
CITIZENS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER ADDITIONAL
COLORS IN SUPPORT AND SUPPORT
OF AB FIVE THIRTY FIVE.
OPERATOR. THANK YOU IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE THIRTY
FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. WE WILL GO TO A LINE OF
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS STEVEN WITH
THE- FROM WITHIN INYO COUNTY I
SUPPORT SB THIRTY FIVE THREE
FIVE ERDELY COMMITTEE THE VOTE
FOR THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND NEXT WE WILL
GO TO LINE OF OCT THIRTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI COMMITTEE
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS FRANCESCA FROM WOODLAND
AND YOLO COUNTY AND I SUPPORT
BILL FIVE THIRTY FIVE I URGE
THE COMMITTEE VOTED FOR THIS
BILL THANK YOU. THANK THANK
YOU. NEXT TO BOTTOM LINE OF
FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN-
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS RUNNING SCALE AND I'M
FROM WOODLAND AND YOLO CUNTY
AND I THOUGHT FOR EIGHTY FIVE
THIRTY FIVE HIGHER DEPENDING TO
VOTE IN SUPPORT OF THIS AT ALL
SINCE YOU. THINK YEAH. THANK
YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF
TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
COMMITTEE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS BIBIANA
VELASQUEZ FROM WILL LAND IN
YOLO COUNTY AND I FOUR EIGHTY
FIVE THIRTY FIVE I URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO VOTE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU. THINK I
WANT TO REMIND THE COLORS WE
JUST NEED YOUR NAME THAT YOU'RE
IN SUPPORT IN AN ORGANIZATION
IF YOU'RE WITH ONE. YOUR NEXT
OF A LINE OF TWENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI COMMITTEE
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS FIONA REGION FROM DANTE
BAKED ONLY. AND DYNAMIC SUPPORT
OF AB FACTORY FIVE THING MY AGE
THE COMMITTEE DEVICE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU WE- WE DON'T EVEN
KNOW ANYTHING MORE THAN YOUR
POSITION IN YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU LINE TO TWENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
CLAUDIA ST I'M A COUNTRY BAND
ALL THE TIME IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIVE THREE FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANNEX BOTTOM LINE UP
TO TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ORANGE BOWL READING AND
ALSO CORPS I DAY TRADE BOUGHT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO SO
LINE OF FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS PAIGE LAW
AND I SUPPORT AP AT FIVE THIRTY
FIVE PLAYERS MANY TO GO. TO
COURT. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO
TO LINE OF FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS QUICK
LITTLE AND THE PRESIDENT OF
COURT- ALL OF THE COMPANY
ASSEMBLY KEEN COUNTY THE
LARGEST CALIFORNIA ALTHOUGH
PROCESSOR AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF
AB FIVE THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
THIS IS SAMANTHA DORSEY
PRESIDENT OF MCEVOY RANCH
CALLING IN IN SUPPORT OF AB.
FIVE THREE FIVE. THANK YOUNG
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
OF FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. LINE FIFTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN TO HAVE A TIME YOU.
EXADATA LINE OF THE THIRTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
KIM HOW I'M WITH MCEVOY RANCH
AND I SUPPORT THE L. A. B.
FIFTY FIVE THIRTY FIVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO TO LINE
OF TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS KEEN TO
SHOW YOUR COMPETENCE CALIFORNIA
HELLO COUNTY I STRONGLY SUPPORT
AB FIVE THIRTY FIVE THAT
COMMITTEE TOOK. THANK YOU
GINETTE MEXICO IT'S A LINE OF
THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS POLITICAL
HARPER I'M FROM WOODLAND
CALIFORNIA. I SUPPORT EIGHTY
FIVE THIRTY FIVE AND URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT ABOUT
THE LINE OF TWENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO A WOMAN
CALIFORNIA. I SUPPORT AB. FIVE
THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU MEXICO
CAROLINA FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
STILL AT THE WEEKEND WITH
FOUNDER BAND DOLLARS AND I'D
SUPPORT AB FIVE THIRTY FIVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT TO GO
TO LINE OF FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MY NAME IS GERRY UP
THE JOB AS A BOARD DIRECTOR AND
SECRETARY TREASURER OF THE
OLIVE OIL COMMISSION OF
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT AB
FIVE THREE FIVE. THANK YOU
MEXICO TIMELINE OF EIGHTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS SAM HARTMAN AND I SUPPORT
EIGHTY FIVE THIRTY FIVE-
COMMITTEE TO VOTE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND NEXT TO GO TO LINE UP AT
FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS KIMBERLY
POINT REDDING CALIFORNIA AND I
SUPPORT EIGHTY FIVE THIRTY FIVE
AND URGED ME TO VOTE YES. THANK
YOU. AND WE DO HAVE ONE MORE IN
Q. OR GETTING THEIR NINE NUMBER
ONE MOMENT. BETTINGER AND WE
WILL GO TO A LINE OF THIRTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
MY NAME IS ALEXANDER FROM DAVIS
AND I SUPPORT AB FIVE THREE
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK
YOU AND WE'LL GO TO LINE OF
FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YOU KNOW- I'M AN OFFICER IN THE
YELLOW COUNTY CHAPTER OF YOUNG
FARMERS AND RANCHERS IN ANY
SPORT AB FIVE THREE FIVE THANK
YOUNG. THANK YOU AND MEDICARE
WE HAVE NO FURTHER- SUPPORT IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU-
THERE IS NOBODY IN THE CHAMBER
OR- AT SIDE SO WITH THAT WE
WILL GO TO OPPOSITION THERE IS
A WITNESS MICHAEL FOX THE CEO
CALIFORNIA OLIVE RANCH IS HE ON
THE LINE. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME
YEP. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
MICHAEL FOX AND THE- CALIFORNIA
OLIVE RANCH THE LARGEST WERE
ABOLISHED RECORD ALBUMS THE
CALIFORNIA. THE SHIP A FIFTY
PARTNER PARTNERS ACROSS STATE-
OUR COMPANY BURKE PROBABLY
ACCOUNTS FOR ALMOST HALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S ALL WILL PROPER
ALTHOUGH. I RESPECTFULLY BABY
BY THIRTY FIVE ENOUGH TO DEMAND
THAT GET THE COST OF LITIGATION
AROUND THIS ON MEASURE. FOUNDED
IN NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT
POPPING WITH MINOR AND IF USING
A BASEBALL PRACTICES IN
CALIFORNIA TODAY WE SELL
PRODUCTS TWENTY NINE THOUSAND
STORES ACROSS AMERICA. IN EARLY
TWENTY NINETEEN YOU WANT A NEW
PRODUCT LINE POWER GLOBAL BLIND
WHICH I CLEARLY LABELED ON A
PLANNED OF CALIFORNIA OLIVE OIL
WITH HIGH QUALITY ALL OF THE
OTHER COUNTRIES. THE PLAN
COMPLEMENTS EXISTING 100%
CALIFORNIA ALL OF OUR LIVES.
PLANNING FOR MULTIPLE SOURCES
OF COMIC ACTORS IN OUR INDUSTRY
OF 60% OF ALL BOOKS SOLD ON THE
MARKET IT ALTHOUGH BLINDED FROM
ALL THE REGIONS OR BLIND OF ALL.
OF WILL HAVE A GRADUAL.
REPORTER THE BABY FATHER FIVE
R. CONSUME LOOKING. ON CLEARLY
MARKED OF DIFFERENT. IS LABELED.
TRADEMARKS LIKE. ALL OF WHICH-
SUDDEN THEY ARE YOU THE- IS.
THE VALUE OF A HUNDRED WELCOME
ALL OF WHICH IS NOT TRUE. BOB
ASSEMBLY WILL DO NOTHING GIPSON
HIM AS ABLE TO THE- BY COMMON
AND USABLE. BUT OF OUR LABELS
AND BOX. IN AND THEN. RESEARCH
AND CONSUMER THAT NINETY OF
CONSUMERS WITH PUBLIC IF
BETWEEN HUNDRED THANKS HEALTH
LINE. AND IT WILL BE. SECOND
THE AVERAGE BREAK LEADER OF A
PERCENT ALL OIL THAT TWENTY.
SINCE THE LAUNCH OF OUR GLOBAL.
THE HOBBIT PERCENTILE ALABAMA
BY LEADER SILVA HUNDRED TWENTY
BECAUSE- SINCE LAUNCHING GLOBAL.
ALL ARE ALL WITH THE HIGH
QUALITY MEETING. STRICT QUALITY
AND OUR NEIGHBOR A TRIPLE MORE
TRAIN THAN ANYONE ALTHOUGH
ALONG MARK TODAY. IF NOT EIGHTY
FIVE THIRTY FIVE WOULD BE. BY
LAW YOU HAVE TO WITH FIVE EIGHT
OR ONE THAT FIRST AMENDMENT
NURSING SPEECH RIGHT. AND
VIOLATE FEDERAL TO LAW DURING
THE WRITTEN ARTICLE AB THIRTY
FIVE AND THAT'S A- THANK YOU.
THANK L. DOING ADDITIONAL. AND
OFF THIS WOULD BE TO JUST STATE
YOUR NAME- AND YOUR AFFILIATION
IF YOU HAVE AND YOUR PIN. GIVE
YOUR ARE NOT. OF AB FIVE THREE
FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE UP
TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I ONE TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ALL CALLS. OKAY WE'LL GO
TO LINE UP ONLINE SIXTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS KIND OF A BECKLEY I WOULD
LIKE TO SAY THE HEARING NINETY
THREE BILLS IN COMMITTEE THIS
MORNING IS RIDICULOUS AND THAT
YOU. DON'T HAVE ANY IDEA
OPERATOR YOU CAN HANG OUT WE
ARE NOT WE ARE TO POSITION IF
YOU WANT TO COMMENT ON A BILL
YOU MUST SAY YOUR NAME YOUR
POSITION IN YOUR FILIATION YOU
HAVE ONE. THAT IS IT. WE HAVE
NO FURTHER OPPOSITION IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME. OKAY I'M IN IS
ANYBODY IN THE BUILDING HERE
TO. SPEAK AGAINST AB FIVE
THIRTY FIVE. ALL RIGHT WITH
THAT. I HAVE A MOTION BY MISS
CARILLO IN A SECOND BY MISS
CALDERON- I DO HAVE QUESTIONS
OKAY. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
PRESENTATION ON THE BILL IT WAS
HER AND I THAT HAD A VERY
LIVELY DISCUSSION IN HEALTH.
AND I WANT TO THANK HER FOR HER
COMMITMENT TO WORK- WITH MY
OFFICE TO TRY TO FIND A
RESOLUTION TO TRY TO. OVERCOME
SOME OF THE CHALLENGES THAT WE-HAVE IN THIS. THIS BILL- ON THE
TECHNICAL SIDE OF IT- I AM
HAVING A HARD TIME GETTING
THERE TODAY BUT I DO HAVE A
STRONG COMMITMENT- TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR AND I WILL LOT LOOK
FOR TO WORKING WITH HER AND HER
STAFF. I'M TRYING TO FIND- AT A
REASONABLE SOLUTION. TO THIS%
BILL. SO THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
I'M HERE THANK YOU. IT'S OF.
WILL CALL WITH THE ON BUILDING.
ALL RIGHT I GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL WITH VOTING HE HAS TO
ACTUALLY BE HERE- HE'S NOT HERE
SOME YEAH THAT'S OKAY I DO
NOTICE IT'S OKAY IT'S OKAY. WHO
ARE A LITTLE ROUGH THIS MORNING
THAT THAT GETS OUT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH DETERMINED AND
COMMITTED. OKAY MR LOW AB EIGHT
FORTY SIX AND ENJOY THE DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION I SEE A MOTION
BY MISS CARILLO AS SECOND BY
MISTER CALDERON. YOU MAY
PROCEED I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. I APPRECIATE THAT WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO THE PHONES IS
THERE ANYBODY IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO AB EIGHT FORTY
SIX. IF YOU WERE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO NOW. ONE IN AND
THEIR APPEARANCE SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE UP TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANKS MY NAME IS
NATALIA FROM MORE THAN ON THE
NUMBER OF TORY. SERVICES AND I
SUPPORT AB FIVE THIRTY FIVE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU
AND NEXT WE WILL GO TO LINE OF.
MY. TWENTY EIGHT. ONE TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
OTHER LADY OFF I DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND SHE WAS TALKING
ABOUT EXPECTANCIES- WE ARE
GOING TO FOLLOW THE RULES EVEN
YOU ANDREA TODAY SO IF PEOPLE
WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION TO AB EIGHT FORTY
SIX THAT IS ALL WE ARE TAKING
IN CALLS RIGHT NOW. ARE THERE
ANY OTHER FAMILIES AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE OF SIXTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS I
FOR YOUR EXACT NUMBERLIVERMORE
IN ALAMEDA COUNTY AND I SUPPORT
EIGHTY FIVE THIRTY FIVE. AND
I'M THINKING OKAY. I JUST SO
EVERYBODY ON THE LINE KNOWS WE
HAVE ALREADY PASSED AB FIVE
THIRTY FIVE WE ARE NOW ON TO AB
EIGHT FORTY SIX IF YOU MISSED
YOUR OPPORTUNITY REGISTER YOUR
SWORD PORT ARE OPPOSITION YOU
CAN DO SO IN WRITING. BUT NOW
WE ARE ONLY TAKING PHONE CALLS
FOR AB. EIGHT FORTY SIX. THANK
YOU AND AGAIN IF YOU WERE IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. A BABY
EIGHT FOUR SIX YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE'LL GO TO
LINE OF- FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MY NAME IS VAGUELY
EIGHTEEN ACT OF NINETEEN SIXTY
SEVEN. CANADA PLEASE THERE YOU.
ARE JUST CANNELLA LAWLER THE-
PLEASE DISCONNECT THE- IS THERE
ANY COLOR FOR THE LINE OF
THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MODERATOR MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE JEREMY
SMITH CANNOT BE HAPPY WITH THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL OF THE SPONSORS.
OF EIGHTY EIGHT FORTY SIX. IT
SIMPLY EXTEND THE COUNTERTOP
RIGHT TO CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND K. TWELVE
DISTRICTS ANALYZE JOB ORDER
CONTRACTING YOU WERE NOT
ASSIGNED WITNESS SO WE ARE JUST
TAKING IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
THERE WAS NO DESIGNATED WITNESS
WE DON'T NEED- TESTIMONY.
APOLOGIZE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU DOES
ANYONE HAVE A QUESTION WITH
THAT HE GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL
CALL THANK YOU MISTER LEFT. WE
ARE MOVING IN. THE GENDER STAND
THAT I MAY BE PRESENTING FOR A
SIMILAR COLOR IS THAT CORRECT.
IT SAYS IT RIGHT THERE I WAS
ABOUT TO READ THAT. BUT I WAS
CONFUSED ALL RIGHT YES- MISTER
LOWE IT WILL. PRESENT FOR
MISTER KALRA ON AB EIGHT FIFTY
SEVEN ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION I HAVE A MOTION
BY MISS CARILLO AND A SECOND BY
MISTER RIVAS RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU WE WILL GO TO
A WITNESS ON THE PHONE IN
SUPPORT MARK SH SH. SH AT.
MEDICARE MEMBERS- MARC SHOT.
HERE WITH CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION WE
AGREE WITH THE CANADIAN
ALLOCATE THAT THE COST OF THE
GLX THE DEVELOPED THE H. TWO A.
FARMWORKER RIGHT CAN NO.
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL ARE
MINOR AND OBSERVABLE WE ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE AND WE'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. HOLDEN
THANK YOU. IS THERE ANYBODY
ELSE ON THE LINE WHO WANTS TO
REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO AB. EIGHT FIFTY
SEVEN. YOUR APPEARANCE BORDER
OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHT FIFTY
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO NOW. ONE AND THEN
ZERO FOR ANY- SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION. THE MANAGER WE HAVE
NO SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME WONDERFUL
READ BACK TO THE COMMITTEE I
SEE NO COMMENTS THAT GETS OUT-
SOME CALL. THAT THAT BILLS
ACTUALLY ON CALL- WE NEED TO
GET A FEW MORE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HERE THANK YOU MISTER
LOKER MISTER KALRA. ALL RIGHT
NEXT. MR GALLAGHER. AB THREE
SEVENTY NINE. ENJOY THE DO
PASSED AS AMENDED TO MAKE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBES ELIGIBLE FOR ADDITIONAL
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
STEWARDSHIP PROGRAMS ARE YOU
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENT YES YES SO ENJOY THE
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION I HAVE A
MOTION BY MISTER BIGELOW IN A
SECOND BY MISS DOLLY. YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS- AB THREE SEVEN NINE
CORRECTION OVER CITING THE
CALIFORNIA CODE THAT THE
CURRENTLY PREVENTS THE
ACQUISITION OR MANAGEMENT. OF
CONSERVATION LANDS BY
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBES. AB THREE SEVEN NINE-
WOULD MAKE THAT MUCH NEEDED
CHANGE AND I DO ASK FOR YOUR I.
THE- THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY
COLORS IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
TO AB. THREE SEVENTY NINE. YOUR
OF YOUR TO PORTER OPPOSITION OF
AB THREE SEVENTY NINE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE
WILL GO TO LINE OF TWENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE TWENTY
EIGHT ABOUT ME. YOU CAN
DISCONNECT THE CALL WE'RE ONLY
TAKING CALLS BUT YOU WOULD HAVE
NO FURTHER I THANK HIM. JUST A
REMINDER WE ARE ONLY TAKING
CALLS FROM PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
ABIDE BY THE RULES WHICH IS
SIMPLY STATING YOUR NAME YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL AN
AFFILIATION IF YOU HAVE ONE. I
SEE. THERE IS A WITNESS UP IN
THE- CALORIE. GOOD MORNING
SANDRA KNIGHT VICE CHAIR THE
MACHINE THE INDIAN TRIBE IN WE
HAVE STRONG SUPPORT FOR THIS
SOMETHING ASSEMBLY AND
GALLAGHER FOR HIS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. I SEE NO OTHER
TESTIMONY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. DISASTER I'VE A THANK
YOU MA'AM JIM. THANK YOU TAKE
IT OUT ON A ROLL CALL. WE HAVE
NET. THANK YOU MISTER NAZARIAN
COMMENT. WAS BETTER R. EIGHT-
WE WILL NOW GO TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WHOSE BILLS- AFTER
PRESENT TIME MISS DOLLY AB
EIGHT OH FOUR ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION I SEE A MOTION
BY MISTER BIGELOW AND A SECOND
BY MISTAKE AS. AB EIGHT OH FOUR
AS A SIMPLE BILL THE CHANGES I
MADE TO A SHALL IN CURRENT LAW
TO REQUIRE RATHER THAN
AUTHORIZE THE DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT FISHING WILDLIFE TO
CLEAR TO FREE HUNTING DAYS WHEN
THE FALL IN THE SPRING. THE
COST OF IMPLEMENTATION WE
BINDER AND OBSERVABLE AND
HEALTH DEPARTMENT FINANCIALLY
OF NEW HUNTERS TAKE UP THE
SPORT AND PURCHASE ANNUAL
HUNTING LICENSE THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION A RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE. ON ON THE PHONE
TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS ARE MARK HENLEY IN
BILL GAINS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. I SEE NOTE QUESTIONS BUT
WE WILL GO TO LINES TO REGISTER
ANY SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO AB
EIGHT OH FOUR. JUST YOUR
POSITION PLEASE. PORT
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. WE'LL GO TO LINE
OF FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AND FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THE MANAGER WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT- THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- WOULD YOU LIKE I SEE
NO QUESTIONS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THIS RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANK YOU THAT GETS OUT
ON A ROLL CALL WITH THE CHAIR
NOT VOTING. MR LEVINE. AB
FOURTEEN OUT OF ROOM. IN THE
BACK WELL I DIDN'T SEE SORRY
MISTER NAZARIAN TO RETURN AB
FOUR SIXTY FIVE. LET OKAY AT ON
AB EIGHT OH FOUR IT WOULD STILL
PASS IS ON A ROLL CALL WITH THE
CHAIR AND MR LEVINE NOT VOTING
OR VOTING NOW. SORRY. VERY AND-
AB FOUR SIXTY FIVE ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION I HAVE A
MOTION BY MISS- THREE OH AND
SECOND BY. MISTER CALDERON
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PROCEED I
JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE. THANK YOU AB FOR SIXTY
FIVE WILL GO TO THE PHONES IF
THERE'S ANY REGISTERED SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION FOR AB FOUR SIXTY
FIVE. THANK YOU IF YOU ARE AT
THE BORDER OPPOSITION OF AB
FOUR SIXTY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE UP TWENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU TAMMY
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE QUALITY
CALIFORNIA ONE THIRD OF THE
BILL IN PRAGUE WHAT. THANK YOU
AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION AND WELL WE HAVE
ONE COMING IN ONE MOMENT PLEASE
MADAM CHAIR OF THE GET THERE BY
NUMBER. AGAIN WE ARE ON EIGHT
BE FOUR SIXTY FIVE IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION. AND WE WILL GO
TO A LINE OF SEVENTEEN YEAR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU SHARE
MEMBERS JERRY DESMOND OF HELP
THE PROFESSIONAL FIDUCIARY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORTER OF POSITIONING QUEUE
AT THE PLANT FALL WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER NAZARIAN
RESPECT REST FOREVER CHECK IT
OUT ON A ROLL CALL THANK YOU MR
LEVINE YOUR LAST UP- MR LEVINE
I'LL BE PRESENTING ON AB
FORTINO TO FROM HIS DESK THAT'S
FINE IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB
FORTINO TOO WILL REQUIRE
MARKETPLACE FACILITATORS TO
REGISTER COLLECT AND REMIT ALL
APPLICABLE FEES REQUIRED TO BE
ADMINISTERED UNDER THE FEE
COLLECTION PROCEDURES LAW I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ABOUT WE
HAVE A MOTION BY MISS FRIEDMAN
A SECOND BY MISTER CALDERON AND
ANYBODY ON THE LINES IN SUPPORT
OF OR OPPOSITION OF AB FORTINO
TO. THANK YOU IF YOU'RE NOT
PROVISIONAL SUPPORT OF AB
FORTINO TOO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN THE
EUROPEAN OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT
OF AB FORTINO. TO THE MANAGER
WE. OUT ON A. B. ROLL CALL WITH
MISS DOLLY NOT VOTING. THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME WE WILL READ
OUT THE BILLS THAT ARE BEING
PLACED ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR-
CAN I GET A MOTION FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. STAVELEY'S IN
A SECOND BY MISS CARILLO PLEASE
READ THE CONSENT CALENDAR. AB
FOUR NINE FIVE BIGELOW AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY BIGELOW AB THREE
THREE FIVE BOERNER HORVATH AB
FOUR FOUR FOUR FOUR FOUR FIVE
CALDERON AB SEVEN FOUR TWO
CALDERON AB ONE THOUSAND FOUR
CALDERON AB TWELVE NINETY ONE
FRAZIER AB THIRTEEN THIRTY
FRAZIER AB TEN FIFTY CRISTINA
GARCIA. AB TWO NINE SIX GIPSON
AB TWO FOUR TO HOLD IN AB TWO
NINETY IRWIN AB ELEVEN FIFTY
SEVEN LEVY AB TWELVE NINETY LEE
AB TEN SIXTY FIVE MAIENSCHEIN
EIGHTY FOUR FOUR ONE MAYES AB
THREE OH SIX O'DONNELL AB THREE
ONE SEVEN PATTERSON AB SIXTY
THREE PETRIE-NORRIS. AB FOUR
SIX SIX PETRIE-NORRIS AB SIX
SEVEN THREE SALAS AB NINE FIVE
SEVEN SALAS SB SIX FOUR FOUR
WALDRON. ACR FIFTY THREE WARD.
AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN-
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY AB FIFTY
TWO COMMITTEE ON REVENUE
TAXATION AB FIFTY THREE
COMMITTEE REVENUE TAXATION AB
FIFTEEN EIGHTY FIVE COMMITTEE
ON HEALTH. YEAH THIS. ALL RIGHT
SO THAT WAS A CONSENT
COUNTERWEIGHT EMOTION A SECOND-
AND THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL I WANT PEOPLE TO NOTICE
HOW MANY BILLS WE PUT ON
CONSENT AND GOT OFF TO THE
FLOOR WAS AWESOME CAN'T FORGET
YOUR TOTAL PEOPLE- JUST JOKING.
NOT REALLY OKAY AT THIS POINT
WE'RE GOING TO. ALSO READ OUT
THE BILLS THAT GO TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE MR SECRETARY. AB
TWELVE SIX FOUR AGUIAR-CURRY AB
SIX HUNDRED ARAMBULA AB FIVE
FOUR ONE BERMAN AB TEN SEVENTY
THREE BERMAN AB TWELVE NINETEEN
BERMAN AB TEN EIGHTY FIVE
BIGELOW AB TWO THREE THREE
BOERNER HORVATH AB TEN ZERO
SEVEN CORREO AB THIRTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN CERVANTES AB THIRTEEN
CHAO EIGHTY FOUR SEVEN THREE
CHAO. AB FOUR SEVEN FOUR CHAO
AB THREE TWO EIGHT CHIU AB SIX
SIX SIX CHIU AB TWO NINE COOPER
AB TWO TO FOUR DALY AB SIX OH
FOUR DAILY ABC EIGHT SIX THREE
FONG AB FIVE TWO ZERO GIPSON
EIGHTY FOUR EIGHT- LEARNING AS
WELL AS AB ONE ONE TO HOLD AND
AB FOUR EIGHT EIGHT IRWIN. AB I
FIVE EIGHT FIVE NINE IRWIN AB
TWO NINE THREE KALRA. AB ONE
EIGHTEEN KAMLAGER AB SIX. THREE
SEVEN LACKEY EIGHTY SIX LEVINE
AB EIGHT TO FIVE LEVINE AB NINE
THREE TWO LEVINE AB NINE FIVE
LOW EIGHTY SIX FOUR SIX LOW AB
ONE ONE FOUR MAIENSCHEIN AB
EIGHT OH FIVE MAIENSCHEIN
EIGHTY FIVE TO ONE MATHIS AB
FIVE FOUR TWO MATHIS AB NINETY
ONE MCCARTY AB NINE FOUR ZERO
MCCARTY AB TWELVE FIFTEEN
MCCARTY AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN MCCARTY. AB ELEVEN
THIRTEEN MEDINA AB EIGHT THREE
FIVE THE SYRIAN AB EIGHT THREE
NINE O'DONNELL AB FIVE EIGHT TO
PATTERSON AB NINE NINE THREE
PATTERSON AB FOUR SIX NINE
REYES AB TWO SEVEN LOSE EIGHTY
SEVEN FOUR FOUR RODRIGUEZ. AB
NINE SEVEN THREE RODRIGUEZ. AB
ONE THOUSAND SIX BLANCA RUBIO
A. B. TEN FORTY SIX BLANCA
RUBIO AB SEVENTY SALAS. AB FOUR
ZERO NINE SARATOGA AB ELEVEN
FIFTY ONE SMITH. AB FOUR
THIRTEEN TAKING AB TWELVE ALL
WANTING AB SIX FIVE THREE
WALDRON A. B. SIX NINE TWO
WALDRON AND AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
FIVE WEEKS. ALL RIGHT SO ALL OF
THOSE WERE MOVED TO THE
SUSPENSE- FILE AND THE AUTHORS
WAGE PRESENTATION SO WE WILL.
BE GOING TO PUBLIC COMMENT IF
DESPITE THEM WAVING
PRESENTATION YOU FEEL IT
NECESSARY TO REGISTER YOUR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO ANY OF
THOSE BILLS THAT IS ALL. WE
WILL- EXCEPT STATE I SEE MISTER
WARD CAME IN AS A RESULT- WE-
CAN SAY THAT AB EIGHT FIFTY
SEVEN AM BY KALRA GETS OUT ON A
B. ROLL CALL THANK YOU. WITH
LIVING NOW. AT THIS POINT.
ANOTHER THE THEY'LL BE
REGISTERED OKAY YEAH I'M
INTERESTED TO BE REGISTERED I'M-
WE ARE NOW GOING TO MOVE TO
PUBLIC COMMENT ON BILLS THAT
WERE MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE FILE
YOU SIMPLY STATE YOUR NAME THE
BILL AN ORGANIZATION IF YOU
HAVE ONE IN YOUR POSITION ON
THE BILL THAT IS ALL OF THE
TESTIMONY IF YOU WILL THAT WORK
SEVENTEEN ON BILLS THAT WERE
NOT PRESENTED TODAY AND HAVE
BEEN MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE
FILE. OPERATE CAN YOU. OPEN UP
THE LINES FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
Q. FOR PUBLIC COMMENT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE
AND THEN ZERO FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT WE WILL GO TO LINE OF
TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I'M CALLING IN OPPOSITION TO A
NUMBER OF THESE BILLS- THIS IS
ANDREA HEDSTROM. AND I AM IN
OPPOSITION TO LEVINE AB SCIEX
LEVINE AB EIGHT TO FIVE LEVINE.
NINE THREE TWO. MCCARTY AB NINE
TWO ONE MCCARTY. NINE FOUR ZERO
MCCARTY AB. ONE TWO ONE FIVE.
MCCARTY AB. ONE THREE SEVEN
SEVEN. O'DONNELL AB THREE OH
SIX O'DONNELL AB. EIGHT THREE
NINE. CHANGE. AB FOUR ONE
THREE- SAYING AB. ONE TWO OH
ONE THREE OH PETRIE-NORRIS AB
SIX THREE PETRIE-NORRIS AB.
FOUR SIX SECS HER. I'M NOT SEEN
A LETTER ALL RIGHT EVEN WHEN
I'M NOT. FEEDBACK WE OKAY. DO
WE HAVE ANY OTHER COLORS.
MEXICO TO LINE OF SIXTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS MARSHALL WITH THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX
FIVE THREE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT SO GO TO LINE OF
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
THIS BY AND SHALL BE DIRECTLY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ACCESS
COALITION AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF AB SIX SIX SIX AND EIGHTY
NINE FOUR ZERO THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND NEXT WE WILL
GO TO ONE OF US SEVENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS KEN OLIVER WITH THE CROP
ORGANIZATION- I'M IN SUPPORT OF
AB. THREE TWENTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU. THE NEXT TO GO TO A LINE
OF SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING CHURCH
GONZALEZ IS A LOT OF MY THAT ON
BEHALF OF THE CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY AND SUPPORT
OF AB FOUR SIX NINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. FAIXA BOTTOM LINE OF
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING SIMON'S- ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF
COMMUNITY BEHAVIOR HEALTH
AGENCIES AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT
OF AB NINE FORTY AND WERE ALSO
A PILE STYLE SPONSOR OF AB SIX
SIX SIX. CAN THANK YOU NEXT SO
GO TO LINE OF EIGHTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THE MORNING SURE
MEMBERS THAT MEASURE THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN
POINT TWO AN EIGHTY EIGHT
THIRTY NINE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO TO A LINE
OF A SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS- WILLIAM AFTER
BURKE MIGHT HAVE PUBLIC
AFFAIRS- REPRESENTING A FEW
DIFFERENT CLIENT THIS MORNING
SO I'LL GO DOWN THE LIST- BLACK
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL. IN SUPPORT
OF AB FORTY EIGHT. SB SIX SIX
SIX AND EIGHTY NINE THIRTY TWO.
I NAY ROUTE PRO TOUR CALIFORNIA
AB TEN OH SEVEN AND GREEN
LINING- IN FRONT THEIR GRAVY
THIRTEEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEXICO TO A LINE OF
EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. A
LINE OF EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. REMEMBERS THE LARKIN OF
GAP CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURES
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THE EIGHTY EIGHT
THIRTY NINE WERE IN OPPOSITION
AT EIGHTY NINETY FIVE AND
EIGHTY THIRTEEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOUNG. THANK YOU NXR GO
TO LINE OF FIFTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE FIFTY A IS OPEN DO
YOU HAVE A TIME YOU. HI BALANCE
WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
PROPERTY IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
THREE TWENTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE
NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT IN Q.
WONDERFUL THANK YOU- WE'VE
TAKEN PUBLIC COMMENT MOVED
EVERYTHING THAT NEEDS TO BE
MADE I THINK WE ARE COMPLETE
WITH APPROPRIATIONS HEARING
TODAY. I WILL ADD IT EDUARDO
GARCIA KEVIN MCCARTY ARE IN THE
BUILDING WE WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR. FIVE MORE MINUTES AND
THEN WE WILL DOUBLE DOWN THANK
YOU. RIGHT YOUR FREE.
CALDERON
THANK YOU SO.